[Applause]
[Music]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
local ssd can add some extra storage
space for your virtual machines
local ssd is local solid-state drive
storage for your vm instances
it provides the lowest latency and
highest performance storage for
temporary use cases
local ssds are physically attached to
the server that hosts your vm instance
giving you superior performance very
high input output operations per second
and very low latency compared to other
block storage options
you can customize the vm shape to your
workload or attach predefined shapes
designed for typical use cases like data
analytics
media rendering or gaming your data is
secure because it's encrypted with an
ephemeral encryption key that's managed
and protected by the ssd
local ssds can be created only during
the instance creation process
after creating a local ssd format and
mount the device
local ssds are designed for temporary
storage use cases
such as caches or scratch processing
space which makes them suitable for
workloads like
media rendering data analytics or high
performance computing
so next time you're thinking about
adding ephemeral storage to your vm
take a minute and look at local ssd for
more info on local ssd
check out cloud.google.com local ssd
[Music]